and get 2 months free.
>> Laura: A NEWLY RELEASED
TEXT BETWEEN FBI AGENTS IS
RAISING QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT TO
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID
ABOUT HIS LACK OF INVOLVEMENT IN
FEDERAL INVESTIGATIONS.
ON SEPTEMBER 2ND 2016, LISA PAGE
TEXTED HER FRIEND PETER STRZOK
ABOUT THE NEED TO CREATE TALKING
POINTS FOR FBI DIRECTOR JIM
COMAY.
SHE TEXTED "POTUS WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING WE ARE DOING."
THAT WOULD APPEAR TO CONTRADICT
WHAT PRESIDENT OBAMA TOLD FOX’S
CHRIS WALLACE EARLIER.
>> I’VE TALKED TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS, I DO NOT TALK TO
FBI DIRECTORS ABOUT PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS.
WE HAVE A STRICT LINES AND
ALWAYS HAVE MAINTAINED IT.
>> Laura: JOINING US NOW IS
JAMES FREEMAN OF
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN IS HERE IN THE STUDIO AS
HIS DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST SCOTT
BOLDEN.
YOUR SENSE ON THIS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING THIS
ISN’T A BIG DEAL.
IF THIS IS A PRESIDENT BEING
ENGAGED ON THE SUBJECT OF
RUSSIAN COLLUSION AND
INTERFERENCE IN THE ELECTION
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE INFORMED
ABOUT.
>> YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT IN
CONTEXT.
JULY 5TH IS THE DAY THEY SAY
WORD NOT GOING TO CHARGE
CLINTON, THE NOW FAMOUS PRESS
CONFERENCE.
LATER THAT SAME MONTH, PETER
STRZOK OPENS THE RUSSIA TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
TWO WEEKS LATER WE HAVE THE TEXT
MESSAGE, HE SAYS WE NEED AN
INSURANCE POLICY IN CASE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE MAKE AN
PRECEDENT.
TWO WEEKS AFTER THAT THEY SAID
HE NEEDS TO DO EVERYTHING WE ARE
DOING.
TAKEN IN CONTEXT I THINK IT
RAISES A LOT OF CONCERNS AND
SUSPICIONS, THAT’S WHY WE NEED
TO LOOK INTO IT AND FIND OF
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON.
>> BARACK OBAMA ISN’T WALKING
THROUGH THAT WHITE HOUSE TOUR,
HE’S A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE DATES AND
DETAILS IT DOESN’T AMOUNT TO
ANYTHING DEFINITE.
YOU CAN LOOK INTO IT IF YOU WANT
BUT WE HAVE A RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION, THEY MEDDLED IN
OUR ELECTIONS, WHETHER
DONALD TRUMP IS CONNECTED TO
THAT HEAD AND HE CAN COLLUSION
OR ANYTHING TO DO WITH THAT
INVESTIGATION, WE ARE TO BE
FOCUSED ON THAT WHETHER YOU ARE
A DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN THAT
OUGHT TO BE THE FOCUS.
THESE DATES IN THESE
POSSIBILITIES AND CONJECTURE ARE
A WASTE OF TIME.
>> HERE’S THE BROADER CONTEXT,
HE SHOULD LOSE 100 MILLION TO
ZERO.
>> IT MEANS THAT THEY HAVE A
POLITICAL VIEW.
>> IT’S NOT JUST BY US, THEY
TOOK ACTION.
>> Laura: LET’S GET JAMES
FREEMAN IN HERE, YOU HEARD THE
DISCUSSION.
THE SPIN TODAY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS IS THIS IS EASILY
EXPLAINED BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD BE AWARE OF ANY EFFORT TO
INVESTIGATE AS A CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AS THE GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATES A RUSSIAN EFFORT TO
MEDDLE IN THE ELECTION
REGARDLESS OF WHAT POLITICAL
PARTY IS INVOLVED, YOUR RESPONS
RESPONSE.
>> IT DOES SOUND LIKE PROGRESS
IF DEMOCRATS ARE ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO REPORT TO THE
PRESIDENT, THEY ARE NOT AN
AUTHORITY UNTO THEMSELVES.
IT GETS TO THIS QUESTION OF WHO
DID AUTHORIZE GOING TO A JUDGE
AND GETTING A WARRANT TO SPY ON
THE POLITICAL OPPOSITION WITH AN
AMOUNT OF EVIDENCE THAT WOULD
NOT PASS MUSTER AT OUR NEWSPAPER
OR ANY PROFESSIONAL NEWSROOM.
NOW THE QUESTION IS, YOU
MENTIONED THE OBAMA STATEMENT ON
YOUR PROGRAM A FEW YEARS AGO,
IT’S QUITE A DISTANCE, I NEVER
TALK TO THE FBI DIRECTOR ABOUT
IMPENDING INVESTIGATIONS, NOT
ONLY DID HE TALK BUT HE WANTED
TO KNOW EVERYTHING THEY WERE
DOING.
I THINK THE QUESTION FOR
MR. OBAMA IS DID YOU REALIZE
THIS EVIDENCE WAS SO THIN?
THAT HE KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
DOING GOING TO THE JUDGE AND THE
FISA COURT WITH THIS POLITICALLY
GENERATED MATERIAL?
>> Laura: I THINK IT IS WILD
TO THINK IN THE MIDDLE OF A
HEATED PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
CYCLE, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
THE FBI READY TO SPY ON AN
AMERICAN, NOT TO GO TO THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK THAT WOULD BE WEIRD NOT
TO SAY WE ARE ABOUT TO DO THIS.
WE THOUGHT WE SHOULD GIVE YOU A
HEADS UP.
AND GO TO THE PRESIDENT AND SAY
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER.
WE THINK YOU SHOULD BE APPRISED
OF THIS.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS OKAY?
>> YOUR PREVIOUS SEGMENT, THAT
THEY HIRED STEELE TO PRODUCE THE
DOSSIER AND THEY ALSO TOLD HIM
WHAT TO PUT IN IT.
DID THEY TELL HIM TO PUT IN AT?
>> Laura: WHO PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER PROBABLY NOT.
>> ONE TIME I WOULD LOVE TO COME
ON THIS SHOW AND IT DEBATED THE
G.O.P. ABOUT FACTS, NOT
CONJECTURE.
NOT GUESSING.
WE DON’T EVEN KNOW WHETHER
BARACK OBAMA ASKED FOR THAT
INFORMATION YOU’RE RELYING ON
THE TEXTS.
>> Laura: YOU’RE A AS I AM,
CONTEMPORANEOUS RECORDINGS
WHETHER IT’S TEXT MESSAGES OR
BOTH CALL RECORDINGS ARE QUITE
RELIABLE IN COURT.
THERE IS NO REASON FOR HIM TO
LIE ABOUT -- NO REASON FOR HIM
OR HER TO SAY, EITHER OF THEM TO
SAY, HE WANTS TO KNOW EVERYTHIN
EVERYTHING.
>> THAT’S HOW THEIR PROCESSING
IT.
>> AND OBAMA’S PROXY ERIC HOLDER
WAS ON ANOTHER NETWORK TONIGHT
WITH RACHEL MADDOW AND I WANT
THE CONGRESSMAN TO RESPOND,
LET’S WATCH.
>> THE REAL PROBLEM IS THE
PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT GOING AFTER NAMED
CAREER PEOPLE, SAYING THINGS
ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF THOSE TWO
DEPARTMENT, THE FBI.
NO OTHER PRESIDENT HAS EVER SAID
TO THOSE KINDS OF THINGS,
CONDUCTED HIMSELF IN THAT WAY.
HE IS DOING LONG TERM.
I THINK ANY ONE OF MY KIDS WOULD
MAKE A BETTER PRESIDENT THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: HILARIOUS.
>> NO OTHER FBI HAS TAKEN A
CAMPAIGN OPPOSITION RESEARCH
DOCUMENT TO SPY ON A FELLOW
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
THAT IS UNBELIEVABLE.
THINK ABOUT THIS, COMEY IS GONE,
McCABE IS LEAVING, LISA PAGE
HAS BEEN DEMOTED AND REASSIGNED,
THE CHIEF OF STAFF IS LIVE IN
THE FBI.
WHEN HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THE TOP
PEOPLE, THE SEVENTH FLOOR PEOPLE
LEAVE THIS ORGANIZATION --
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
IF THAT’S WHAT WE’RE TRYING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF COME OF THE
TEXT MESSAGE GIVE CONTEXT TO THE
WHOLE MIND-SET OF THESE PEOPLE